lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
pensar en como los impuestos pueden
afectar un producto si la demanda de
este producto es muy elástica como
ejemplo tenemos el mercado de cierto
tipo de banderas hechas en china en este
momento el precio de equilibrio donde se
intersectan las curvas de la oferta y la
demanda se encuentra en 70 pesos por
bandera la cantidad demandada en
millares por año es aproximadamente 25
mil banderas si el precio aumenta un
poquito por encima del punto de
equilibrio qué va a pasar si el precio
aumenta un poco las personas van a
comprar las banderas hechas en taiwán o
corea o en cualquier otro lugar son muy
parecidas y nadie notará la diferencia
así que comprarán otras opciones más
baratas así que si el precio aumenta
aunque sea muy poco la cantidad de la
demanda se verá muy afectada si el
precio disminuye un poco entonces las
personas ya no comprarán las banderas
hechas en otros lugares y comprarán
estas banderas más baratas por lo que la
demanda será mucho mayor lo que tenemos
aquí es una
manda con una elasticidad muy alta y muy
larga aquí tenemos una demanda casi
perfectamente elástica si fuera
perfectamente elástica estaría
completamente horizontal un cambio muy
pequeño en el precio ocasiona un cambio
enorme en la cantidad de la demanda si
hablamos de porcentajes un cambio de
porcentaje pequeño en el precio causa un
cambio muy grande en el porcentaje de la
demanda digamos que a alguien del
gobierno no le gusta que la bandera de
mexico se fabrique en china por lo que
decide poner un impuesto a estas
banderas de mexico hechas en china en
este ejemplo vamos a imaginar que el
impuesto es una cantidad fija aunque
también podría ser un porcentaje si
fuera así entonces cambiaría la forma de
la curva de oferta más impuestos ésta
tendría un cambio porcentual en lugar de
un cambio fijo y es más sencillo dibujar
un cambio fijo así que tenemos un
impuesto fijo de 5 pesos por bandera
como será la curva de la oferta más
impuestos para fabricar una bandera en
china e importarla y almacenarla en
le cuesta al fabricante más o menos 53
pesos y ahora con el nuevo impuesto a
este costo se le agregan los 5 pesos
ahora la curva de la oferta más
impuestos estará por acá agregamos 5
pesos a todos los puntos de la curva de
oferta esta curva es la oferta más
impuestos y esta otra es la de oferta
ahora qué pasa aquí nuestro precio de
equilibrio eran 70 pesos y ahora el
precio de equilibrio sigue igual
prácticamente no ha cambiado pero la
cantidad de equilibrio si ha cambiado ha
disminuido drásticamente parece que
ahora esta cantidad es igual a 18 mil
banderas por año quién va a asumir oa
cargar el peso de esto pensemos en el
impuesto sobre el ingreso en este caso
son las 18.000 banderas por 5 pesos aquí
están los 5 pesos por 18 mil todo esto
es el impuesto sobre el ingreso observen
que todo esto sale del excedente o
superávit del productor
el excedente original del producto
suponiendo esta demanda casi
perfectamente elástica
el rectángulo verde más esto y esto esta
área pequeña de aquí es la pérdida de
peso muerto todo esto surge del
excedente del productor por lo que si
tenemos elasticidad perfecta de la
demanda por el producto la persona que
tendrá la carga tributaria será el
productor esto es algo interesante
porque cuando tenemos una demanda casi
perfectamente elástica una curva de
demanda casi horizontal no habrá
excedente del consumidor porque el
beneficio marginal en cualquier punto
para el consumidor de esta siguiente
unidad es igual al precio que está
pagando en una curva de demanda
perfectamente elástica y perfectamente
horizontal no existe un área entre la
curva de demanda y el precio pagado por
lo tanto no existe un excedente del
consumidor para pagar el impuesto sobre
el ingreso todo sale del excedente del
productor nos vemos en otro vídeo